la parole est à monsieur geor F ou merci
monsieur le Président s'il vous plaît
monsieur chers collègues monsieur le
gardess à la suite de la publication
d'entretien intime accordé par le chef
de l'État à deux journalistes du Monde
c'est toute la magistrature qui est vend
debout pour manifester son indignation
et sa stupéfaction en effet François
Hollande y étale son aversion pour le 3è
pouvoir je le cite cette institution qui
est une institution de lâcheté parce que
c'est quand même ça tous ces procureurs
tous ces haut magistrats on se planque
on joue les vertueux on n'aime pas la
politique il ajoute même ce n'est pas
une engance facile la magistrature il ne
faut vraiment pas commettre de faute on
peut être
lyché depuis certes il y a eu
l'expression des regrets du président
mais le mal est fait et Monsieur le
Ministre la semaine dernière vous me
répondiez déjà en me disant qu'il faut
juger le chef de l'État sur ses actes
alors dont acte je vous invite à lire
cet aveu dans le même livre page 404 je
cite en septembre 2014 le chef de l'État
n'a pas placé par hasard un homme sûr
proche de lui à la tête de la direction
des affaires criminelles et des grâces
où convverg le plus légalement du monde
les données sensibles issues des
dossiers judiciaair grâce à la
Chancellerie Hollande a donc pu sans
influer sur leur développement veulent
se rassurer les journalistes obtenir des
remontées d'information portant sur
certaines procédures en cours et de
conclure le chef de l'État l'assume
totalement alors ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
garantir devant la représentation
nationale qu'en aucune façon la justice
n'est instrumentalisée à des fins
politiques et qui n'existe à l'Élysée
aucun cabinet noir en liaison avec votre
ministère prendriez-vous toutes mesures
si cela étéit le cas pour y mettre un
terme merci la parole est à Monsieur
jean-jac curvois garde des saut ministre
de la Justice
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Député
fénec l'exercice s'appelle les questions
gouvernement vous en connaissez les
règles j'en connais les
principes je connais votre question vous
me l'avez déjà posée vous connaissez ma
réponse je vais vous la répéter le
gouvernement depuis 2012 que celui que
ce soit celui de Jean-Marc HUD avec
Christian tobira ou celui de Manuel Vals
avec Christian tobira et votre serviteur
vous a proposé à deux reprises des
textes l'un organique voire
constitutionnel l'autre était ordinaire
pour proposer pour proposer qu'il n'y
ait aucun lien entre le parquet
c'est-à-dire celui qui est l'autorité
poursuivante et l'exécutif ces deux
textes c'est non mais je comprends que
ça vous courousse que je vous le
rappelle je
comprends
monsieur le député vous le savez et je
le dis sans aucun esprit de vindicatif à
votre égard votre groupe n'a voté ni r
cette majorité monsieur le député sonore
en 2013 d'avoir voté un texte j'en viens
à votre question mais mais j'en viens
mais laissez-moi le temps de construire
en 2 minutes ce qui peut s'apparenter à
une réponse qui soit
argumentée en 2013 un a été voté qui qui
interdit qui interdit au gouvernement de
donner des instructions individuelles
sur n'importe quel dossier et comme si
cela ne suffisait pas nous vous avons
proposé de modifier la Constitution pour
que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature ne puisse plus aussi être
avoir des perturbations politiques vous
avez refusé nous avons accepé et donc
franchement sur ce sujet franchement
nous n'avons strictement aucun ordre ni
aucun conseil à recevoir merci Monsieur
le gade
desessau la